(upbeat ukulele music)
(Skype calling sound)
- Yeah, hello!
- There's a giant hand on the screen.
- Oh hey, Mom, can you
make yourself landscape?
There we go!
- You're on camera now.
- OK, you are filming now, right?
- [Eugene] Yes, you look very beautiful.
- Oh, thank you. I don't think so.
- So how are you? We never
really FaceTime, you and I.
- [Zach] We talk on the
phone a bunch, but we never,
I never think to FaceTime you,
it's nice to like, see you.
- [Keith] So we're all
Skyping with our mothers
to talk about motherhood.
- [Zach] We've been
shooting this big series
of videos exploring parenthood.
- How are you finding it?
- [Ned] How am I finding it? (laughs)
- Well, I, uhm...
- I learned a lot about what you had
to go through three times.
- Like, I knew that being
a parent was really hard,
but it's so fucking hard.
- Some of the things that we've done:
we started with wearing
fake pregnancy bellies.
- [Eugene] There's something
called "labor pain simulation."
- Then we got to play with a baby,
which was the cutest baby in the world.
- So we also, you know,
remember when we had
those robot babies in school?
- [Keith's mom] (laughs) Yes!
- [Keith] We had to have
those robot babies again.
(Keith's mom laughs)
- So I was wondering what, you know,
what your pregnancy was like,
what having me was like.
- Pregnancy with you was tough.
- No, it wasn't difficult.
- You know, you didn't kick me.
- You used to run in place.
- Oh, OK!
- I gave birth in the
summer, and I was, you
get very hot at the end.
- [Zach] Ugh!
And I also got very fat.
- So I made you fat and sweaty?
- You did indeed.
- The doctor told me
your heartbeat is faster,
so everybody, including
doctor, thought you were girl.
- Oh! (laughs) You thought
I was a very silent girl?
- Yes, yes.
- At one point, I had to,
I had to have bedrest,
so you and I watched a
lot of old "I Love Lucy"s.
- Oh!
- You liked like feeling when I kicked?
- Totally.
- It wasn't like, "What is
this monster inside of me?"
- I loved it 'cause it made it real.
- Right. Yeah, we didn't
have a real thing,
we just had a little pouch with baby goo.
- What was it like when you delivered me?
- I mean, was that the most painful thing
you've ever experienced?
- It was awful, I was screaming.
I think the whole hospital
must have heard me.
- Well, down the hall, there
were these women screaming!
- (laughs nervously) Oh no!
- Some pain, but you know,
you know, I love kids.
- And at one point,
your heart rate dropped.
And, it wasn't scary, but I guess,
something was going on
that they said to me,
"OK", and you know, it
was far enough along,
they said, "Alright, we
gotta get him out now."
- In your case, I had
you in fifteen minutes.
(Keith laughs wildly)
I went from 5 to 10 in fifteen minutes
in little bitty ol' Smith County Hospital.
- [Eugene] You know, I'd
never held a baby before.
- Oh, you never?
- No!
- I had my first experience
changing a diaper.
- You remember the first
diaper you ever changed?
- Oh, yeah! It was - I
didn't tell them about it.
- You made mittens!
- Yeah, I made like, paper towel mittens
so I wouldn't get poop on my hands,
'cause I was like twelve.
- Did I poop a lot?
- Every baby poops a lot.
- How was I like when I was a little baby?
Was I crying a lot?
- Oh no, you didn't cry.
- You liked music, so we
played this tape dad had
called "Trumpet a Go-Go."
- You were a good baby, you always
made everybody smile and
laugh! You were just like now.
- Sounds like me.
- Well 'ama', it's Mother's Day.
- Oh, yes!
- So, I wanted to call you
and say that I love you.
- You know, I tell you I love you a lot,
I hope I do. I hope you know
it, I think you know it.
- All of these things
that we've done have been,
like, simulations, right? They
haven't been the real thing.
- Is there anything else
that you experienced
during motherhood that was significant?
- Like what?
- (laughs) I don't know,
I'm not a mom! I don't know.
- We did this whole thing
to just try and like see
if we could understand what
it's like to be a parent,
what it's like to be a mother,
and what I realize is,
I mean, I'll never know.
- Through this process, I've been able
to imagine the bigger
picture a little bit.
- Don't let the Try Guys'
Mother's Day videos scare you.
Whatever you go through,
it's well worth it,
and it's awesome to be a
mother and look at these kids!
Look what I raised. I'm so lucky.
- Raising kids is a real joy. It's joyful
and it's [inaudible]. I believe that.
- Parenting is full-time,
24 hours, all the time.
- And I'm always, always
happy to be your mother.
- Thank you.
(soft sobs)
- Are you really crying?!
- Yeah, I don't know. I love you so much.
- I love you too, sweetie.
- You're like the best
person in the entire world,
you're so important to me.
- Thanks for giving birth to me.
- OK, thank you, you're welcome.
- Happy Mother's Day on
Sunday! I'll call you though.
- Thank you so much for
talking to me, I love you.
- Oh! You're welcome!
- Well, happy Mother's Day, momma.
It's a really amazing thing
and I feel like I have
a deeper understanding of it
and a greater perspective.
I love you very much.
- I love you too!
- Thanks for being my mom.
- OK, talk to you then, bye-bye!
- Bye!
- How do we get out of this now?
(laughter)
- [Keith's mom] Bye!
- Bye.
That was classic.